[Musique]
vous avez vu danser vous alors vous a
jamais vu danser mais moi j'en ardent
c'est nancy russe adorée dans ce cas
comment fait je pense que tu vas faire
là dessus toi parce que vous vous êtes
toujours classe toujours toujours belle
on va vous mettre des musiques essayer
d'en c'est toujours avec la classe mais
en donnant d'accord attention est ce
qu'il est capable comme ça taux des
prêts à temps des attentions
[Musique]
oui
c'est là on va faire on va faire un truc
voile et j'étais complètement improvisé
cette histoire une histoire
christina vous êtes tranquillement boîte
parce que tout le monde vous adore tout
le monde est franchement moi je vois une
fille comme vous je n'attache pas
d'accord qui est un podium est arrivé à
la maison je ferme touche unis ça y
était madame hanoune à droite et madame
cordula d'accord bon bah je vais appeler
je vais appeler je m'appelais
jean-michel baer la plus sûre michel mr
[Applaudissements]
je vais ap il pas trop jeune pour voulu
non ça va ça va il faut juste m'aimait
bien j'ai pas comme vous me cassez est
là les blaireaux sont même bien
[Applaudissements]
attention regardez vous êtes en bois ton
train de danser d'accord et il ya un
gars vous allez arriver chacun votre
tour
on va le faire aussi 1 il va essayer de
vous draguez monde en sont devenus dans
c crosser et le gaz va arriver vous vous
voyez vous pouvez le basez vous voyez
pas d'accord non mais bien le mec qui
l'attend il est comme ça alors laisser
l'un peut danser au début après vous
auriez compris les espoirs bertrand
chamerois d'abord d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
agacé la chlamydia est la classe il est
arrivé à l'ex son costume chirac 82
secondes et il est arrivé le gars
c'était alain juppé l'épargné comme à
son ministre sur la bbc
et là c'est parti
les trois mouvances pourquoi il avait
choisi le gérant demain que ce n'est pas
parce que ouais tout un coup d'arrêt à
classer dans la vérité si l'arrivée on
dit pour l'habitat il ya du pognon à
quoi on le voit rien on est où là il ya
du pognon alors je vais vous dire je
vais prendre déjà tout de suite et jean
michel vous faites du convient de 43 43
excusez moi parce qu'on va pas rester
deux heures donc si on peut dépendre les
chaussures parce que le glaive alors il
veut vraiment choisir les sociétés
[Rires]
renommées sort le gars je vais voir je
vais aller si gérard louvin venez là 20
qui doit faire qui doit faire du 44 du
renvoi 44 allez-y j'ai fait jean luc
joly jean-luc et easy 3d celle que vous
voulez attention venez-vous cina qui
arrive ou pour exhaler 43 allez-y s'il
vous plaît faites samedi
merci de me dire rien aller-retour à
faire chez vous plaît regarde regarde et
thierry moreau est magnifique dessus je
me demande si ça lui va pas mieux
attention un aller-retour à faire [ __ ]
téléphone alors moi je suis l'arbitré
monde en titre ne peut pas non plus
faire la ps vita il ne pense pas qu'il
vient à temps jean michel maire est prêt
en tout cas d'ailleurs moi et ça lui va
comme un gant
mais c'est vrai je suis jolie est
magnifique
attention les gars vous allez pas
mettez-vous là vous faites un aller
retour
donc attention christina christine à
faire avec eux aussi attention un peu on
n'a pas perdu
vous n'irez pas des météorites à moi
petit d'aucune avait vécu j'avais été
qu'une année pas sûr mais aussi sous la
mitraille à vos marques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]